a new trailers out for Westworld season
2 and it hints at some of the themes
that we'll see in the series ahead if
you haven't seen our season 1 video you
might want to watch that first in this
trailer
dolorous talks about burning down the
human world and building a new world
where the hosts the robots can be free
so Dolores seems to be waging war
against the humans remaining in West
world we see her gunning down fleeing
people like something out of Planet of
the Apes her victims run away which
makes the Kanye soundtrack all the more
appropriate Dolores isn't alone in a war
she's got her sidekick Teddy who mostly
just follows her around and looks upset
but she also has these mysterious masked
men we're actually told who these guys
are back in season one charlotte
mentions that as part of his final
narrative Ford created a horde of masked
men who support Wyatt and Wyatt remember
is like the big bad guy role from years
ago that's now been embraced by Dolores
so basically these masked men will
probably help Dolores in her fight for
freedom against the humans but that
raises the question if this whole story
of Wyatt and the masked men was planned
out by Ford is Dolores really free or is
she still under Ford's control even
after his death may've also attacks
humans she uses robot bulls to kill
security guys in the Mesa hub and
there's also a fight in the control room
where Maeve made seismo last trailer the
bull thing calls back to something
Dolores said last season when you herd
cattle there's a Judas steer that all
the other cows follow maybe Maeve is the
Judas steer leading the other hosts to
consciousness and freedom but the thing
is while the cattle follow the Judas
steer
that Judas steer is controlled by the
human cattle rancher just as Ford seems
to be controlling Maeve and Dolores so
again Ford's ghost looms over the story
still another explanation for the Bulls
is that last season Maeve is upgraded
with the ability to control other hosts
she uses this on a sheriff and even on
Bernard this power might be how Maeve
controls these Bulls which is super cool
for her to control an animal
me like she was ant-man or Squirrel Girl
or some homicidal version of Snow White
but if Maeve represents freedom isn't it
wrong for her to control other hosts
like this to take away their freedom
again it's kind of like how Ford gives
hosts freedom by manipulating them
anyway Maeve's goal at the end of season
1 is to find her host daughter somewhere
in a park what will happen when Maeve
finds her what kind of relationship can
you have with a daughter who's a robot
whose memories and behaviors are
programmed how can you love a machine
there are lots of cool questions to
explore around relationships among
robots and humans while Maeve and
Delores cause chaos and violence some
surviving human staff are with Bernard
it'll be cool to see how these humans
react if they find out that their boss
Bernard is a host the staff see bodies
on the shore of West world which might
be what's left after Dolores is massacre
last season we also see Bernard with a
big faceless host who attacks someone is
this like an experimental robot maybe a
military thing we keep hearing last
season that the delos company has some
special business interests that goes
deeper than tourism maybe this creepy
robot is related we also see the host
Peter Abernathy captured in the Mesa hub
which is weird because last time we saw
Peter he was sent out of West world by
Charlotte and Sizemore who were using
Peters brain to smuggle data if Pete
left the park why is he back here maybe
this shot happens in the past because
there's also this shot of Logan young
Logan as he looked 30 years ago with
William it looks like season 2 will
continue to tell their story in multiple
time frames at once
there's the present with Maeve and
Dolores as uprising and there's the past
with William and Logan thirty years ago
maybe we'll find out more about how
della bought Westworld and how William
took control over Logan this particular
shot looks like Logan's in the real
world outside of West world because
there's cities sky escapes behind him
this might be New York like in the photo
of Logan's sister Juliet but the people
around Logan in this shot appear to be
hosts because the
like frozen so this is not only the
first time we've seen the real world
outside West world but we're seeing
hosts out in the real world what kind of
role do robots play in this future
society what kind of technology and
culture might we see this shot might
also be in the past
it looks like Arnold with an early
Dolores so if maybe we'll see more of
their backstory
Dolores wears a dress and hair similar
to Angela in season 1 episode 2 maybe
Dolores was originally going to be a
greeter host like Angela also remember
that Peter is Dolores as host father so
maybe we'll see more of their
relationship we'll also see more of
young William and his present self the
man in black last season William wanted
real danger and violence in West world
and now with Dolores as war he's got his
wish his role last season was to show
how dark and empty humans can be maybe
next season will be an opportunity for
William to change to believe in
something more than just fighting and
winning we see hosts from ghost nation a
mysterious tribe of Native Americans in
the West world Park they captured Stubbs
last season and might have him still but
their role in the story could also go
deeper we saw last season that these
guys know things about the maze and
about shades they also scalp people
which is interesting because it was in a
scalp that we first saw the symbol of
the maze so it's not clear what side
ghost nation will take in Dolores and
Maeve's conflicts but it'll be cool to
learn more about what they know we also
see this dog or wolf walking around it
looks like the same one that appears in
a season 1 finale and in season 1
episode 2 why does this wolf keep
turning up at massacres is that
wandering across from the Game of
Thrones set you can actually see a
wolf's head in this shot of Arnold and
early Dolores so maybe this wolf is like
a host that's been wandering around for
the last 30 years it's very odd so there
were lots of little miscellaneous
mysteries in this show and we might not
get good answers to all of them but
there is a grand
story the central image of this trailer
is the clash of these robot bulls
against human soldiers which perfectly
captures the conflict explored in this
series it's about freedom versus control
and the real versus the artificial and
it's increasingly hard to tell which is
which
the robots are machines but they seem
wild and free like Dolores and Maeve
these soldiers are the real humans but
they seem cold faceless and dehumanized
like the man in black Westworld season 1
is described as a prequel or a prologue
to the greatest story it introduces the
characters world and themes but season 2
is where the clash happens man and
machine West world and East world
present and past it all comes together
at last
season two begins on April 22 if you
want more Westworld videos from alt
shift X make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and comment what you'd like to see next
we do have a season 1 video if you
haven't already seen that which explains
the intricacies of the timeline and
Ford's plan and all of that stuff we
also got our Game of Thrones videos with
analyses of theories characters and more
thank you to the patrons who make all
shift X possible including Ryan Yusef II
who Juan Camilo Rodriguez Nicole Tovar
Kristen Graham King Fred the Easter
Bunny and shaped like bacon Cheers
you